hey guys welcome back to brandy if you
were doing something a little bit
different today these are my stream
highlights of all the times I've been
streaming for Hunter and we'd find some
dumb [ __ ] so we got tons of stuff in
here so I'll just basically shut up and
let you watch this you want to check out
my streams I stream every single
Saturday at around noon EST you can use
your time so roughly run every Saturday
a stream so if you do want to come in
catch some of these dumb moments as well
live definitely hop in I put a lot of
for honor of course on stream and other
stuff like that in the future but yeah
I'll see you guys later enjoy the video
and just tweak his own I'll take a nerf
to the zone if I can get a better reflex
card I think we can I think most
gladiator pita players can agree with
that you don't always have to rely on
his own about to do mad [ __ ] damage
right now oh my god a hundred and one
did the damage off a ballista is so
whacked especially when I had the damage
buff
that's disgusting can't stand the new
gear stats change yeah I find that gear
stats changed to be very confusing
I personally like perks more I'm about
to drop on this dude Bob [ __ ] played
not the greatest in like she's good in
duels she's not the best character she's
really good fours
this is stupid that we're doing this
I don't even know what that was Black's
garden buff I mean if they need to get
rid of his if they need to make his own
less powerful so that they can do that
I'm all game for it again but you hate
to see the helmet of Perry's you hate to
see these Perry's back and forth when
he's wasting his invincible feet you
hate to see it sir and he buffed himself
on how [ __ ] you dude oh I almost [ __ ]
knocked my headset off bro you [ __ ]
hate to see it baby let's get it so I'm
playing which is yeah good fly it's hot
dog good stuff did you check your audio
setting I'd turn it to music Vaughn
because it was all the way down when I
open the game I didn't actually let me
I'll check that in a sec oh what the
[ __ ] yeah turn that [ __ ] up didn't hell
yea why is it like that
oh hell yeah
good that that was a very scary moment
what
the [ __ ] was that I'm supporting the
team just by sitting in this deep
officer Authority
oh [ __ ] I just heard every neck
but you're still vibrating hold up
you good
it's the dude it's still going what the
[ __ ] is up with this guy hi there you go
what is this guy's problem what I
thought for sure that was gonna be a
block I thought for sure I was gonna be
Perry Perry wait a minute hold on geez
paragon teammate wait hold on I gotta
check that what the [ __ ] was that
[ __ ] off they [ __ ] away from me me I'm
run No I'm be I'm being this [ __ ] I'm
[ __ ] called me I was gonna say I'm
gonna be the shinobi and run away oh you
gotta be kidding me really what timing
yeah good Oh what is that
what the [ __ ] is that bro my head's in
my ass
Oh Lord it's actually annoying and
lights on Council are just not good you
know that already that's just not good
in general also I never under the
perfect timing to talk about this why
the [ __ ] does Centurion of sharpened
blade
I never understood that personally I
don't understand why he has sharpened
blade huh
it's such a weird feet for him to get I
mostly see assassins having his feet why
does he get it
that's how we clutch it up boy a
survivalist team let's get [ __ ] going
let's go big clutch I did it a little
too early
could you dad for me there you go there
goes half my audience no I don't mean to
roast you but uh ever since you did the
face reveal I see is Kevin's cousin buzz
from home alone [ __ ] Devon Rowe I do
my boy Devon bro
we're all taking the fight together I
like it you mean the one person that's
on
I [ __ ] unplugged in my head I plugs my
headphones when I did that I don't like
her she's okay but she's still annoying
is the hook source character gonna be an
assassin and what do you think of the
did well the D [ __ ] we gonna do I have
no clue I think she's gonna be an
assassin no clue on what the hoax are
gonna do
so I'll buckle stop shocks the game has
been broken since released that's true
men preach it shinobi give back foot but
of a sucker in any time really the [ __ ]
no what no shinobi like ever does that
though if that's true I've never seen a
shinobi do that all right Andre [ __ ] it
up dude
all the D flag that's gonna be all that
was a [ __ ] crazy ass play oh my god
holy [ __ ]
Andre you killing it bro
this game are too easy
no problem love you man no homo yeah man
no homo less you trying to make it full
o'Nuts I'm okay with either option [ __ ]
marry kill options la bring a Raider
shaman um hmm got it
I'm gonna kill shaman I'm gonna marry
Raider and I'm gonna I'm gonna have la
daddy [ __ ] me cuz I want the whole force
of the law in my ass see I'd do that
damn it he's yeah he knew I was coming
[ __ ] telling you but I'm getting killed
from people off screen as well dude no
way I didn't walk that what do you mean
he's actually just gonna pull army oh my
god another renewed lock him in that
wall all right how many times is still
gonna come off screen and hit me like
and I get kunai
did he throw that through while bringer
leaving us - of course speculate and I'm
gonna get hit again with this dude it
alright that time is not my that time
it's my fault because I saw that and
this whole team is on me yeah what the
feel my wrath broke get out of my face
alright there's a lot of what the [ __ ]
Oh bro again again man how many times is
this still gonna come off screen and
kill me holy [ __ ]
Shaolin what are you doing brother
what the [ __ ] was that not this time
brother
let's see you this time Wow Wow why does
it do so much holy [ __ ] you [ __ ] hurt
oh my god you know the Raiders coming
off screen everybody's coming off screen
today dude the [ __ ] Barak who is a very
good player is also involved I'm not
sure about I haven't asked you'll be
[ __ ] kidding me
[Music]
you
[Music]